- [Voiceover] You have two
fractions, 1/4 and 5/6,
and you want to rewrite
them so they have the same
denominator, and have
whole number numerators.
What numbers could you
use for the denominator?
So here's our fractions, 1/4 and 5/6,
and we want to rewrite these fractions
to have new denominators.
So we currently have a four
and a six as our denominator,
and can we just put any new thing,
like maybe five, could we say,
"Let's change them both to
have five as the denominator."
The answer is no.
We have to pick a multiple
of four and six, a multiple,
some number that we can multiply four
and get this number as an answer.
So, for example, for four,
so multiples of four would
be four times one is four,
four times two is eight,
four times three is twelve,
and so on, those are multiples of four
and let's just pause here
and look at why we have to pick
a multiple of four and six,
why we can't just pick any number,
but we have to pick a
multiple of our denominators.
So the fraction we were
just talking about was 1/4.
We could look at either
one, but let's look at 1/4.
Here we have a picture showing
fourths, and to show 1/4,
we shade one of these
four equal size pieces.
Well, maybe I want to change this
and I want to say I want two,
I want two as my numerator.
So to have a numerator of two,
I'm gonna need to split this
fourth up here into two pieces.
Now I have two shaded pieces.
So can I say this is two, one, two, out of
one, two, three, four, five pieces?
It's not 2/5 because these
are not equal size pieces.
So if I split this fourth
right here in half,
I need to split all of them in half,
and what I'm doing is
doubling the amount of pieces.
So now this is two pieces,
this is two, and this is two
because we need equal size pieces.
So now, this is one, two pieces
out of one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight
equal size pieces, so 2/8
and you can see, eight
is a multiple of four
because we multiplied by
two and that's what we did,
we multiplied each of our pieces by two
and we also multiplied
our numerator by two
because that was also doubled.
The amount of shaded pieces doubled
when the entire amount of pieces doubled
and we don't have to
do this just with two,
we could do any multiple of four.
For example, we can do one more here.
If we, again, let's shade 1/4,
one of the four pieces
and maybe this time we
want to split it into
three equal size pieces.
So to have a new numerator of three,
and these should be equal sized,
here's a numerator of three,
but it's, we can't do our denominator yet
because we don't have equal size pieces,
so to get equal size pieces,
we'll need to split each of
these fourths into three.
So we are tripling the amount of pieces.
So now we have three shaded pieces
out of a total of one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, out of 12,
and I could have figured that
out without even counting
because I knew that we tripled this time,
we multiplied our original
denominator times three,
we tripled, and we also multiplied
our numerator times three
so these are the multiples,
eight, 12, and so on
and so those are the
denominators we can pick.
Something that we can
multiply our denominator by
so we can multiply the
entire amount of pieces
and again, so this is super clear,
1/4 and 2/8 and 3/12, they
all represent the same amount,
whether we had 1/4, the
original, here's 2/8, 3/12,
they're all equivalent, they
all represent the same amount,
they're just different ways
of writing the same number.
Back to our original question,
what denominators can we use
for fourths and for sixths?
Well, we know we need to use multiples,
so let's look at the multiples.
For four, we've already
gone through some of these.
The first multiple of four is
four times one which is four,
second multiple of four is
eight, four times two is eight,
so we could split our fourths
into, in half and get eighths
or we could say four
times three is twelve,
which we showed again
where we split our fourths,
each fourth into three equal pieces
or we could do four
times four which is 16,
four times five is 20, four
times six is 24, and so on.
The reason I'm stopping at 24
is I've looked at my answer choices
and I can see the largest
possible answer is 24
so I don't need to write
any larger multiples.
There are many, many, many
more multiples of four,
but we don't need to list them all
because the largest number
we're gonna have to consider is 24.
Let's do the same for six.
We could leave our six
alone, six times one,
and keep six pieces, or
we could double our six,
six times two would be 12,
if we doubled the pieces
we would have 12 pieces.
We could say six times three, which is 18,
or six times four, we could divide
each of our sixths into four pieces
and we'd have six times four which is 24,
or twenty-fourths and so on.
Again, I'll stop at 24 since it's the
largest number we need to consider.
So down to our answer choices,
what numbers could we
use for the denominator?
Could we use eight?
Let's look at these lists.
Eight is a multiple of four,
so we could definitely
split fourths into eighths,
but eight is not a multiple of six,
so we cannot split sixths into eighths,
so eight will not work as a
denominator for both fractions.
How about 12?
12, we can see, is a multiple of four,
and we showed that, we drew that already,
and 12 is a multiple of six,
we could split our sixths
into two equal pieces each
and we would have twelfths.
So 12 does work, 12 is a denominator,
a common denominator
for fourths and sixths.
18, 18 is here on the sixths,
we could split sixths into 18
because 18 is a multiple of six,
but it is not a multiple of
four, so we can rule out 18.
18 is not a common denominator
and 24, you may remember,
was the last number we
wrote on both of them
so yes, 24 could be a denominator
for fourths and sixths.
So we could use either 12 or 24
and there's a lot more
numbers we could use, too,
as common denominators
but from these choices,
we could use 12 or 24
as a common denominator
for fourths and sixths
and just a note, lots of times
people like to use the smallest one,
the least common denominator,
which in this case is 12,
and it makes a lot of sense
because it's easier to do
computation with smaller numbers
but you don't absolutely
have to use the smallest one.
You could use twelfths
or twenty-fourths or,
or lots of other options, but, again,
twelfths is probably the
simplest one to work with
just because generally it's easier
to work with smaller numbers
but for this question, the
common denominators we can use
from these choices for fourths
and sixths are 12 and 24.